bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du chaos alors quand on entend ce mot
dans le langage courant le chaos se
signifie en gros que c'est le bordel
mais en mathématiques ce terme à un sens
plus spécifique qui fait notamment
référence à cet effet devenu une
expression courante
l'effet papillon
[Musique]
la théorie du chaos fait partie de cette
branche des mathématiques qu'on appelle
l'étude des systèmes dynamiques
alors petit point de vocabulaire un
système dynamique ça désigne en gros un
truc qui évolue dans le temps on a plein
de systèmes dynamiques en physique qu'il
s'agisse du mouvement des planètes de la
trajectoire des boulets de canon bien
des oscillations d'un pendule mais on en
a aussi en chimie quand on suit le
déroulement des réactions en biologie
avec l'évolution des populations en
électronique en économie et c'est ce que
les mathématiciens aime bien faire pour
étudier un système dynamique c'est d'en
prendre une version un peu idéalisée
décrite à partir d'une équation
d'évolution prenons l'exemple du pendule
il existe une équation je vais pas vous
l'a détaillé qui permet de calculer la
trajectoire d'un pendule et d'en faire
une simulation ça se fait très bien avec
un ordinateur
on se fixe un point de départ ici un
angle un disons 80 degrés et on regarde
comment le pendule évolué à partir de là
en appliquant les poissons d'évolution
dans les systèmes de ce type ce qui est
important c'est qu'ils sont déterministe
il n'y a pas de hasard qui interviennent
et on peut simuler leur évolution sans
aucune ambiguïté si je relance le calcul
de la trajectoire du pendule eh bien je
vais obtenir exactement le même résultat
l'autre caractéristique importante c'est
que même si on ne connaît pas super
précisément la position de départ bah
c'est pas bien grave si je lance le
pendule avec un angle de 90 degrés au
lieu de 80 mais ça va pas dramatiquement
changé le résultat comme vous pouvez le
voir pareil avec la trajectoire d'un
boulet de canon ainsi je fais deux
simulations en variant les angles
initial de 1 degré eh ben les deux vont
pas tomber hyper loin l'un de l'autre
dans la science telle qu'elle se
pratique depuis newton
il ya cette idée que bien sûr les mêmes
causes provoquent les mêmes effets ça
c'est le déterminisme mais aussi que des
causes similaires vont provoquer des
effets similaires et du coup si on se
trompe un tout petit peu au départ ça a
des conséquences qui sont limitées et
quelque part c'est un peu la base de la
méthode scientifique dans une expérience
on n'arrive jamais à tout décrire de
façon parfaite mais on sait qu'on peut
négliger tout un tas de petits trucs
sans que ça change fondamentalement le
résultat final et pourtant les vous
connaissez peut-être des situations de
cette idée marche assez mal te dérange
ou au billard
si vous essayez de faire disons plus de
trois ou quatre bandes vous savez
peut-être que le moindre changement sur
l'angle initiale peut vous amener dans
un coin complètement différent de ce que
vous aviez prévu
il existe un système physique
qui représente bien cette idée c'est le
double pendu le double pendule c'est
simplement un pendule au bout d'un
pendule
si vous voulez en voir un je vous
renvoie la vidéo de docteur norman sur
le sujet moi j'en ai pas alors je vais
juste en faire une simulation les
équations qui décrivent l'évolution d'un
double pendules sont un peu plus
compliquées que celles d'un pendule
simple mais avec un ordinateur - y'a pas
de problème
et regardez le genre de trajectoire
qu'on obtient l'évolution du double
pendule n'est pas du tout régulière elle
est plutôt erratique et semble
franchement imprédictible c'est très
différent du pendule simple et surtout
regardons ce qui se passe avec deux
doubles pendule lancé avec juste une
minuscule différence sur l'état initial
ici il ya un écart de seulement 1 degrés
entre la position initiale du pendule
bleus et seul du pendule orange et c'est
parti vous voyez qu'au début les deux
mouvements sont similaires mais quand
quelques secondes ils se séparent et
deviennent complètement différent
contrairement un pendule simple
l'évolution d'un double pendule est
extrêmement dépendante de sa condition
initiale les valeurs exactes des angles
et c'est cette sensibilité aux
conditions initiales qui fait qu'un
double pendule est un système chaotique
et donc imprévisible si on avait un vrai
double pendule et qu'on voulait calculé
à l'avant son évolution en faisant une
simulation il faudrait mesurer son point
de départ avec une précision fabuleuse
puisque la moindre variation changerait
complètement le résultat ce phénomène de
petites variations au départ ayant des
conséquences importantes à terme c'est
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'effet
papillon
[Musique]
l'histoire de l'effet papillon ne nous
vient pas du double pendule mais de la
météo
la météo c'est aussi un système
dynamique un truc qui évolue dans le
temps est assez agaçant au premier abord
puisque comme chacun sait on n'arrive
pas à prédire correctement le temps
qu'il va faire avec plus de quelques
jours d'avancé
c'est quand même assez frustrant surtout
quand on compare ça avec d'autres
phénomènes naturels comme les marais
qu'on prédit sans problème pour toute
l'année ou encore les éclipses qu'on
sait prédire à la minute près plusieurs
siècles en avance on pourrait penser que
c'est parce que pour la météo il ya trop
de choses à prendre en compte
la température la pression la vitesse du
vent et ça en chaque point de
l'atmosphère terrestre
ça peut faire potentiellement des
millions de paramètres à considérer pour
mieux comprendre ce à un météorologue
américain edward lawrence avait décidé
de travailler avec un modèle ultra ultra
simplifié de l'atmosphère
avec seulement trois paramètres 3 c'est
vraiment pas beaucoup hein c'est comme
si pour décrire l'état de toute
l'atmosphère à un instant donné
on ne regardait que trois nombres par
exemple la température la pression et la
vitesse du vent mais juste en moyenne
sur toute l'atmosphère
c'est comme si tout le bulletin météo de
la terre tenait en seulement 3 nombre
alors en réalité dans le modèle proposé
par lawrence c3 nombre n'était pas
exactement la température la pression et
la vitesse du vent enfin pour
schématiser on va faire comme si c'était
le cas pour faire sa lorraine ses
parties de trois équations décrivant une
version très simplifiée des mouvements
de l'air dans l'atmosphère
ensuite lawrence a fait ce qu'on a fait
avec le pendule il a pris une situation
de départ et il a simulé ce qui se
passait avec un ordinateur
à l'époque c'était à la fin des années
60 son ordinateur était une bête de
course appelée royal mcbee lgp 30 un
monstre disposant de 16 kg est cadencé à
00 00 12 giga hertz
le tout pour la modique somme de 50
mille dollars des dollars de l'époque en
plus mais ça a permis à lawrence de
simuler ses équations et voilà le genre
d'évolution qui l'a obtenu vous voyez
ici la variation dans le temps de ces
trois variables
on remarque qu'elle oscille de façon
plus ou moins coordonnées mais qu'elle
change de temps en temps de façon
apparemment assez erratique
sauf qu'un jour lawrence avait arrêté sa
simulation et il s'est dit plus tard
qu'ils voudraient bien la reprendre pour
la pousser un peu plus loin il aurait pu
la redémarrer complètement au début il a
laissé évoluer plus longtemps mais il se
dit qu'ils pouvaient très bien la
reprendre au milieu pour reprendre
mullah sion au milieu c'est simple on
prend des points intermédiaires qu'on
avait trouvé dans le calcul précédent
par exemple ceux ci ont les rentrer dans
l'ordinateur comme nouveau point de
départ et on refait tourner les
équations alors comme prévu les
trajectoires ont commencé de façon
identique
et puis à sa grande surprise elle se
sont séparés de ce qu'il avait déjà
obtenu pour évoluer de façon
complètement différente à lawrence a
évidemment été étonné un il a cru que sa
machine avait une pâle ou une
défaillance
et puis il a trouvé l'explication pour
relancer sa simulation il avéré entrer
dans l'ordinateur les nombres qui
s'était affichée à l'écran de son calcul
précédent or ceci n'était donné qu'avec
trois chiffres par exemple 5,16 alors
que l'ordinateur lui dans sa mémoire en
stocker 6 du genre 5,16 1963 et du coup
lawrence croyère relancer sa simulation
en partant du même point mais comme il
se baser uniquement sur les trois
chiffres
il avait recommencé en partant d'un
point très légèrement différent de ce
qu'il avait fait avant et c'est pour ça
que les deux courbes ont divergé le
point initial n'était pas exactement le
même
lawrence venait de découvrir que son
système d'équations pourtant très très
simple et est extrêmement sensible au
choix du point de départ à la condition
initiale et que même en prenant deux
points de départ très très proche les
évolutions finissait par être différente
quand il a raconté sa découverte dans
une conférence quelques années plus tard
il a donné à son exposé un titre restée
célèbre
est ce qu'un battement d'aile de
papillon au brésil peut provoquer une
tornade au texas et c'est comme ça
qu'est née l'expression l'effet papillon
il faut passer un peu de temps sur le
sens réel de cet effet qui est souvent
un peu dévoyé
ce que nous dit lawrence c'est que si
vous voulez prévoir s'il y aura une
tornade au texas dans disons un mois en
théorie vous pouvez mais en pratique ça
veut dire qu'il vous faut connaître avec
une précision extrême l'état actuel de
l'atmosphère terrestre
puisque la moindre petite différence
initiale peut mener à une évolution
différente
un mois plus tard si vous voulez que
votre prédiction soit juste avec un mois
d'avancé
il faut que vous preniez en compte tous
les mouvements de l'air les plus infimes
jusqu'à ce que provoquerait les ailes
des papillons et ainsi on peut très bien
avoir une situation où avec un certain
papillon brésil on a une tornade au
texas un mois plus tard mais si on
l'enlève et bien la tornade disparaît
alors malgré tout ça veut pas dire que
ce papillon est la cause de la tornade
dans l'interprétation l'effet papillon
il faut bien comprendre ce qu'on entend
par le terme pour
ok ok avec le papillon tornade sans le
papillon pas de tornades mais ça se
trouve en gardant le papillon mais en
ajoutant une mouche ailleurs on aurait
aussi supprimer la tornade et en
enlevant deux papillons belle serait
revenu ça n'est pas un papillon qui
causent la tornade la tornade est la
conséquence de l'ensemble des conditions
initiales de l'atmosphère qui a évolué
et la sensibilité aux conditions
initiales est telle que tous les
minuscules détails comptent et vont en
quelque sorte conspiré pour donner la
tornade au texas
c'est important de bien comprendre ça
parce que le concept de l'effet papillon
a été beaucoup repris dans la culture
populaire notamment dans le cinéma d'une
façon un peu détourné la conséquence
pratique de l'effet papillon c'est que
si vous vouliez prédire la météo qu'il
fera dans un mois il faudrait connaître
l'état actuel de l'atmosphère avec une
précision ahurissante et comme
évidemment ce n'est pas le cas on n'a
pas des capteurs ultra précis en tous
les points l'atmosphère et bien il y a
une limite fondamental à ce qu'on peut
prédire dans le domaine de la météo quoi
qu'on fasse on pourra jamais faire mieux
que disons deux semaines est d'ailleurs
de façon ironique le simple fait de
parler de la météo
créer des mouvements d'air qui auront un
impact sur le temps qu'il va faire dans
quelques semaines et vous voyez que cet
effet papillon n'est pas spécifique du
fait que l'atmosphère est un système
très riche à décrire les équations de
lawrence décrivent une atmosphère ultra
simplifié à seulement trois paramètres
en tout et elles sont déjà sujette à ce
phénomène
alors on pourrait s'arrêter là mais on a
à peine effleuré certaine beauté des
systèmes chaotique et pour les regarder
de près on va considérer le plus simple
d'entre tous encore beaucoup plus simple
que les équations de laurens
[Musique]
le système chaotique qu'on va voir
maintenant est très simple pour deux
raisons la première c'est qu'il n'ya
qu'un paramètre à suivre la deuxième
c'est qu'il n'évolue pas de façon
continue comme un double pendule ou la
météo mais pas à pas prenez un nombre x
entre 0 et 1 ce sera notre point de
départ
l'étape 0 et appliquer lui la
transformation suivante 4 x x x 1 - x
par exemple si je pars de x égal 0 37
j'arrive à 0,93 et recommencer appliquer
la même transformation vous tombez sur
0,25 et recommence et ainsi de suite
c'est très simple vous pouvez même le
faire avec un tableur si on trace le
résultat obtenu sur une cinquantaine
d'étape on obtient un comportement
apparemment complètement erratiques
maintenant faisons le même calcul en
partant non pas de 0.37 mais en ajoutant
1 millionième c'est-à-dire 0,3 cent
soixante dix mille 001 et voici ce qu'on
obtient au début les deux courbes se
superposent mais dès qu'on a atteint une
quinzaine d'étapes
elle se sépare et suivent des chemins
complètement différent pour un petit
millionième d'écart au début ça veut
dire que notre système a une énorme
sensibilité au point de départ à la
condition initiale
c'est un système chaotique soumis à
l'effet papillon ce petit système
chaotique hyper simple s'appelle la
fonction logistique et il est inspiré
d'un modèle très élémentaire d'évolution
de population tels qu'on pourra en avoir
en biologie mais ce qui est fascinant
c'est que si on le modifie très
légèrement et bien son comportement
change
prenons la même transformation mais en
remplaçant le 4 par 1 2 ça a l'air assez
bénin comme changement
et pourtant regardez le comportement
qu'on obtient j'ai pris quelques points
de départ différent et en quelques coups
à peine on converge vers 0,5
c'est pas du tout chaotique 1 au
contraire pour ce système 0.5 est ce
qu'on appelle un attracteur si je change
mon deux ans 1,6 on a toujours un
attracteur mais dont la valeur est
différente a à peu près 0,38 et pour un
coefficient de 2,8 la tracteurs et à
0,64 alors essayons maintenant avec un
coefficient 3,1
là c'est bizarre les combes finissent
par osciller en permanence entre 0,76
0,56 on a un attracteur qui n'est plus
un point mais plus
points à tour de rôle la tracteur est ce
qu'on appelle une orbite périodiques
un peu comme l'orbité d'une planète est
une trajectoire qui se répète là on a
une oscillation périodiques entre deux
valeurs avec un coefficient de 3,5 le
système aussi le cette fois entre quatre
valeurs et à 3,56 huit valeurs bon à ce
rythme là on va arrêter de faire ça à la
main et on va programmer tout ça pour
faire un graphique
voilà en abscisse on va mettre la valeur
du paramètre de croissance le
coefficient entre 1 et 4 et on va
simuler le système avec tout un tas de
valeur et pour chacune on va tracer les
points où les orbites vers lesquels ils
se stabilisent
ici on a déjà trouvé quelques valeurs eh
bien on va lancer des gros calculs pour
toutes les autres
et voilà le diagramme qu'on obtient
entre 1 et 3 on converge toujours vers
un attracteur qui est juste un point et
dont la valeur est de plus en plus
élevés et puis à partir de trois on
passe à des oscillations entre deux
valeurs le point où on a un changement
de comportement s'appelle une
bifurcation et puis un peu plus loin ça
sera divisé puis à nouveau et c'est
alors on pourrait croire que ce qu'on va
voir après sont encore des divisions
successives mais non en fait on peut
montrer qu'à partir de trois points 57
on a un vrai changement de nature et on
entre dans un comportement complètement
chaotique sans aucune orbite périodiques
c'est exactement ce comportement qu'on a
vu initialement quand le paramètre
valait 4 ce qui est bizarre c'est que
quand on regarde le diagramme de près on
voit des zones où le chaos disparaît et
on retombe sur des orbites périodiques 1
comme ici pour le paramètre autour de 3
83 où on a des oscillations entre trois
valeurs et si on zoome sur ces zones de
calmes ces bandes blanches on retrouve
des bifurcations à l'intérieur et on
voit qu'elle se reproduise avec le même
motif de dédoublement suivi à nouveau
d'une petite zone chaotique puis d'une
mini zone de calme et on peut zoomer à
nouveau dessus injuste autour de 3 854
et retrouver des bifurcations et ainsi
de suite
le diagramme de bifurcation possède une
structure dite fractale c'est à dire qui
se répète au fur et à mesure consomme
dessus
il faudrait probablement faire une vidéo
entière sur les fractales ça viendra en
attendant je vous renvoie à celle de la
chaîne chou romanesco vache qui rit et
intégrale curviligne qui a fait un très
chouette épisodes sur le sujet et puis
abonnez-vous à sa chaîne allait vraiment
super bien la notion de chaos et celle
de fractal entre
des rapports étroits même s'ils ne sont
pas faciles à saisir les fractales
semble surgir à plusieurs endroits quand
on considère les systèmes chaotique on
l'a vu dans le diagramme de bifurcation
précédent mais on va voir que c'est
également le cas avec le système de
laurens
[Musique]
on l'a constaté quand il est dans un
régime chaotique le système obtenu par
la fonction logistique semble prendre
des valeurs de façon aléatoire est passé
par tous les nombres possible entre 0 et
on peut se demander si c'est la même
chose avec le système de lawrence est ce
que les trois paramètres passe par
toutes les valeurs possibles
eh ben pour le savoir on va tracer leur
évolution en trois dimensions
si vous avez un graphique en 3d pour
représenter la valeur des trois
paramètres de lawrence un point dans un
diagramme représente si vous voulez
l'état de l'atmosphère à un instant
donné
avec sa température sa pression et sa
vitesse du vent et on va regarder la
trajectoire qui suivent à partir d'un
point de départ que vous avez ici
et voici ce qu'on obtient en appliquant
les équations l'évolution fait comme des
tours autour d'un point puis de temps en
temps elle s'en va faire des tours
autour d'un autre point alors se faire
une rotation aux accents pour que vous y
voyez clair
et on voit que la trajectoire des signes
comme une structure qui ressemble à deux
ailes de papillon et oui encore une
histoire de papillons bon mais on a dit
que le système de lorraine c'est un
système chaotique
alors pour le voir lançons l'évolution
depuis un autre point de départ très
voisin du point précédent
ici on a deux positions de départ une en
bleu et une en orange et elles sont très
très proches
d'ailleurs on les distingue pas et si on
lance l'évolution ça se passe pas comme
tout à l'heure
et puis vous voyez que finalement les
deux évolutions se séparent mais par
contre les trajectoires s'accumulent sur
la même figure de papillons et si je
m'amuse à lancer l'évolution depuis
plein de points différents éloignés les
uns des autres
eh bien on obtient la même chose des
trajectoires différentes mais qui
s'accumulent tout sur la même figure
cette espèce de figure en ailes de
papillon agit comme un attracteur qu'on
appelle la tracteurs de lawrence mais ça
n'est pas un point unique ou une orbite
périodiques comme on peut voir avec les
systèmes simples la tracteur à une troll
de forme et les trajectoires semble de
sauter de façon aléatoire d'une aile à
l'autre sans qu'on puisse deviner à
l'avancé ce qui va se passer comme le
modèle de lorraine c'est un modèle de
météo très simplifiées on peut avoir
envie d'interpréter ça en disant que
l'une des ailes de la tracteur
correspond à du beau temps et l'autre à
du mauvais temps alors c'est évidemment
un petit peu plus compliqué que ça par
contre on connaît un système dont le
comportement ressemble un peu à celui de
lawrence c'est le champ magnétique
terrestre
comme je le disais dans mon épisode sur
la structure interne de la terre ce
champ est dû à des mouvements du métal
liquide dans le noyau externe dont la
physique et un peu analogue de celle de
l'atmosphère et les inversion du champ
magnétique qui se produisent parfois à
l'échelle géologique de façon
apparemment aléatoire correspondent à
des changements brusques dans les
mouvements du métal et qui sont
comparables à ce qui se passe quand la
trajectoire du système de lawrence saute
d'une composante à l'autre de la
tracteur mais il ya plus que ça avec 16
autres acteurs déjà à l'époque de son
article fondateur lawrence avait eu
l'intuition qui devait avoir une
structure particulière mathématiquement
sur un attracteur les trajectoires ne
peuvent jamais se couper et donc
lawrence avec compris qu'il ne pouvait
pas s'agir d'une simple surface
il devait y avoir une sorte de
millefeuille de surface empilées les
unes sur les autres et qui se répéterait
à l'infini la tracteurs de lawrence
possède en fait une structure fractale
un attracteur fractales c'est évidemment
quelque chose de très différent des
attracteurs comme les points fixes ou
les orbites périodiques
depuis on a appelé ça hein attracteurs
étranges
sauf que si cette un tracteur est
vraiment fractales avec une structure en
millefeuilles là on devrait pouvoir
observer cette structure engouement un
peu comme on a fait avec le diagramme de
bifurcation alors en théorie oui mais en
pratique c'est impossible à voir il
faudrait bien trop zoomer mais il existe
un autre système beaucoup plus simple en
mesure de révéler la structure fractale
de son attracteurs étranges la
transformation de et non
[Musique]
la transformation de hénon a été inventé
par l'astronome français michel et non
et elle ressemble à la transformation
logistique c'est à dire avec une
évolution discontinuent pas à pas mais
simplement avec une dimension plus on
regarde un point xy du plan et on le
fait évoluer à chaque étape selon la
transformation suivante x devient un
mois 1,4 x carré plus y est y devient
0,3 x très facile à simuler là aussi
alors prenons un point de départ
quelconque et calculons son évolution
et voici ce qu'on obtient et si on prend
un autre point de départ
idem et un troisième et voilà quel que
soit le point de départ
eh bien on voit qu un attracteur se
dessine avec une forme un peu bizarre
alors est ce que c'est un attracteur
normal ou un attracteurs étranges
c'est-à-dire fractale alors ici j'ai
laissé la simulation tournée
suffisamment pour bien dessiné la
tracteurs et on va zoomer sur ce qui
semble être un regroupement de quelques
lignes et voilà ce qu'on observe les
lignes se dédouble et on peut à nouveau
zoom et est révélé que chaque ligne est
faite de plusieurs lignes et ainsi de
suite
[Musique]
la tracteurs de hénon qui avait l'air
d'être une figure simple est en fait
bien un intracteur étrange avec une
structure fractale
pour la petite histoire je vous ai dit
que pour le système de lawrence cette
structure fractale était très compliquée
à mettre en évidence et ça a été
mathématiquement démontré en 2002 par
tucker et deux ans plus tard en 2004
quelqu'un a enfin pu observer la
structure fractale par des calculs mais
il lui a fallu les faire en conservant
sans chiffres après la virgule la notion
d'un tracteur étrangers très importante
car elle nous montre qu'un système
chaotique n'est pas un système qui fait
n'importe quoi de façon apparemment
aléatoire
son évolution est imprévisible en
pratique mais elle suit des régularités
puisqu'elle convergent vers la tracteurs
on a vu qu'avec le système de lawrence
on a bien un effet papillon l'évolution
d'une trajectoire dépens de façon
extrêmement sensible du point de départ
mais deux trajectoires différentes vont
quand même se balader autour du même un
tracteur une question qu'on peut se
poser c'est que si on s'amuse à
interpréter une d elle comme le beau
temps et l'autre comme le mauvais temps
est ce qu'on peut avoir deux points de
départ très proches mais qui évolue l'un
avec
majorité de beau temps et l'autre une
majorité de mauvais temps et bien la
réponse est non si on s'amusait à
regarder les trajectoires suffisamment
longtemps
on verrait que l'une et l'autre passe
autant de temps dans chacune des deux
portions de la tracteurs et on peut même
rendre plus fort ce résultat si vous
prenez n'importe quelle petite région de
la tracteur si on laisse le système
évolué suffisamment longtemps et bien
n'importe quelle trajectoire finira par
y passer et avec la même fréquence que
toutes les autres quel que soit le point
de départ
en pratique si on reprend le cas de la
météo ça veut dire qu en variant
légèrement la condition de départ on
peut avoir ou ne pas avoir une tornade
un moment donné à un endroit donné
mais qu'à la fin les deux évolutions
contiendront autant de tornades
l'une que l'autre donc deux choses
importantes à retenir sur l'effet
papillon d'une part on l'a dit s'il ya
une tornade ce n'est pas la faute de ce
papillon en particulier et d'autre part
s'il n'avait pas battu des ailes en fait
la tornade seraient quand même arriver
mais simplement à un moment différent
c'est d'ailleurs déjà ce qu'avait
anticipé lawrence dans sa fameuse
conférence il écrit avec les années les
minuscules perturbations n'augmente ni
ne diminue la fréquence des événements
météo comme les tornades
le plus qu'elle puisse faire est de
modifier l'ordre dans lequel ces
événements se produisent les systèmes
chaotique de ce type sont imprévisibles
dans les détails des évolutions mais si
on regarde les choses statistiquement
sur le long terme
eh bien ils sont au contraire
relativement prévisible et insensible
aux conditions de départ dans cette
vidéo pour l'instant on a surtout parlé
du système de lawrence et de quelques
transformations simple mais on sait
maintenant que les évolutions chaotique
sont partout en astronomie par exemple
c'est à dire quelque chose que poincaré
avait déjà notée à la fin du 19e siècle
et on peut considérer que c'est lui le
premier qui a mis le doigt sur ces
notions de chaos et d'effet papillon
dès qu'il y a trois corps ou plus en
interaction gravitationnelle
on a un système chaotique autant dire
que c'est évidemment le cas du système
solaire l'astronome français jacques
laskar a pu calculer qu'au delà de
quelques dizaines de millions d'années
la trajectoire des planètes devient
totalement imprévisible et qu'il
faudrait connaître leur position
initiale à quelques mètres près pour
voir le faire l'incertitude est
particulièrement grande pour les
planètes interne que son mercure vénus
la terre et mars en simulant des
milliers de destins envisageable lascars
a même montré que quelques pourcents des
scénarios possibles sont instables et
peuvent conduire à l'éjection de mercure
de son orbite et
la collusion avec une autre planète si
on revient sur terre certains billard
sont aussi des systèmes chaotique alors
pas le billard classique en fait un qui
ne l'est pas à proprement parler mais
des milliards d'effort mehdi
hyperbolique et de façon générale dès
qu'on a des équations d'évolution non
linéaire où on multiplie une variable
par une autre on peut avoir un système
chaotique
c'est le cas en particulier en mécanique
des fluides et c'est ce qui cause le
phénomène de turbulence
mais aussi dans certains circuits
électroniques des réactions chimiques ou
même les rythme cardiaque
l'idée système chaotique est vraiment
perturbante parce que les évolutions ont
beau être parfaitement déterministe on
sait que quoi qu'on fasse aussi puissant
que soient nos ordinateurs
il existe un obstacle fondamental au
fait de pouvoir les prédire et qu'on ne
pourra jamais dépasser ça la théorie du
chaos fait partie avec la mécanique
quantique et le théorème de gödel de ces
grandes découvertes du xxème siècle qui
ont sérieusement plombé l'ambition des
humains de pouvoir tout connaître par la
science merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo
comme d'habitude laïque et partager
abonnez-vous la cloche tout ça si vous
voulez plus de détails mathématiques
j'en ai mis pas mal dans le billet de
blog qui comme toujours accompagne la
vidéo je vous recommande aussi la vidéo
de dr nordmann qui a notamment invité
les de la chaîne syrienne son rôle pour
parler du double pendule et enfin si
nous les creuser vraiment il ya le film
chaos qui a été fait par des
mathématiciens et dont je vous mets le
lien en descriptions voilà merci à
bientôt